the rescue that's the focus of tonight's
angle the scenes today were not
reassuring after the president bomb the
hoties and called a lid early last night
he bumbled his way through a school in
Allentown today this is Morgan Sherwin
and uh
Sam with our
allies secretary a I do I'm sorry how
you doing was it a in judment for not to
tell you
I hope that poor girl got extra credit
for having to sit there now just as we
see the deterioration of our cities
beset by crime by migrants we also see
Biden's own deterioration with each
passing day simply getting from Marine
One to his car is a Herculean
task
and he has the darnest time saying
sentences with numbers on my watch
instead of infrastructure week America
is having infrastructure
decade
decade over a billion 300 million
trillion 300 million billion 300 million
trillion yeah Nico used to say things
like that when he was three now let's go
back a decade or so it's Friday we'll
have fun with this well Joe at that
point could at least be edited to look
[Music]
[Applause]
peppy otherwise we're going to be in
trouble with Jill and Michelle just let
Michelle know I did drink this all right
same time next week same time next
week Obama getting through that that
that better have been vodka but that was
2014 and now the Biden campaign is
scrambling to find ways to make Joe
appear
vigorous but is it
working Mr President why did you learn
about the balloon I love how he does
that little Trot and then realizes I
better not keep running well they push
him out for his first campaign speech at
Valley Forge but then Dr Jill has to
rush in for the big save at the end
[Applause]
[Music]
I don't
care want
to me
aart at this point the first lady almost
deserves the title doctor since she's
been rescuing him on almost a daily
basis but the bidens have such little
regard for the intelligence of the
American people they think that they can
message this problem away one of the
things that Drew me to him was his
strength I see that strength and that
resilience and that steadiness every
single day he has wisdom he has
experience he knows every leader on the
world stage he's lived
history
what we now have a new synonym for
ancient it's called lived
history well she may be his Visiting
Angel but she's America's eyes and ears
he can do it and I see Joe every day I
see him out you know traveling around
this country I see his Vigor I see his
energy I see his passion every single
day so to those who say I can't vote for
Joe Biden he's too old what do you say I
say his age is an
asset and as for that report that
Biden's have been on the vacation more
than a third of the
presidency what people don't see is how
hard Joe works every single day that he
gets up thinking what he can do for the
American people and he does that you
know it his job doesn't end when we just
have dinner together at 7 o'clock it
he's on the phone and he's on the phone
with leaders of foreign countries and
he's on the phone with his
cabinet when Wheel of Fortune's over
he's hard at work but wait a second did
you say he's on the phone this cabinet
at night was medicine cabinet because we
know he wasn't on the phone with his
most important cabinet secretary at
least who should be Lloyd Austin for at
least four
days the vigorous tireless Biden didn't
even notice his Pentagon Chief was
missing
but you're supposed to ignore that that
ignore the fact that your president's
decomposing in front of you and instead
you're supposed to worry about the guy
who brought you peace and prosperity
this has got to be so different than any
races that you and your husband have run
yeah um a little scary it is a little
scary we have to win we must win we
cannot let go of our
democracy
and if you
don't I don't know can't even think
about it no I can't think about
it well of course Donald Trump doesn't
jog he doesn't need to pretend to jog
neither does he need Melania to act as
his nursemaid or his co-president now no
one doubts that he's the one making the
tough calls and that his tough talk
isn't an act it's not sustainable for
our country we have millions and
millions of people here it is not
sustainable did you see in New York City
with it getting the regular students out
and they're putting migrants in their
place we are going to have the largest
deportation effort in the history of our
country we're bringing everybody back to
where they came from we have no choice
we have no choice of course he's right
and he understands that America can no
longer be a superpower if we drain our
own Resources by allowing Free Riders to
take advantage of us would you be
committed to Nato for example in a
second Trump turn depends if they treat
us properly look NATO was taking
advantage of our country they took
advantage of us on trade and then they
took advantage of us on our military
protection of the 28 countries at the
time only eight countries were paid up
we were paying the difference and I went
to them I said if you don't pay we're
not going to protect
you well weakness incompetence and
self-loathing is what the Biden ad
Administration has shown us and shown
the world from day one even Trump's most
fervent detractors though like writer
Brett Stevens they're beginning to see
even if they don't agree with them why
he's winning the working class is
getting shafted and Trump's the only one
speaking for them America needs a leader
who can navigate the headwinds that
we're facing they're strong headwinds
someone who knows how to do the job and
who believes in and works for the
American people and until we get one
America's going to grow with weak and as
frail as our current president and
that's the angle hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else